en première ligne vous avez toujours la
figure masculine c'est normal c'était
des matches où les corps se sont ils
encore clair ils sont
comment dirais-je exubérant ils sont
excessifs is an mais en deuxième ligne
c'est toujours la femme la mère enfin en
particulier suis viscéralement attaché à
ma tête je vous ai dit et pas de chose
qui me ferait partie de suivre des
chaînes comme ma fille plus que mattel
c'est une passion cette cause et si on
l'est mais on peut pas la détruire
au contraire on fait des jours je suis
de plus en plus rebelle - quand je vois
tout ce qui se passe en corse
ailleurs ça m'intéresse pas moi je suis
dit si je suis enraciné
j'aime ma culture j'aime j'aime ma
petite île mais grand mère m'ont
toujours appris la passion de la sainte
vierge dans les moments de désespoir
c'était toujours la sainte vierge au mas
donne au mas donnons le thi hoa donat
[Musique]
quand je pense à la corse où je suis né
je revois tous ces hommes qui respectent
leur mère qu'ils vénèrent les madones
qui glorifie les martyrs je me souviens
que je ne me reconnaissais dans aucune
de ces figures féminines et que ça a
participé à mon besoin de partir me
construire ailleurs
n'étant ni maman ni sainte vierge je me
demande quelle place on peut prendre ici
vraiment en tant que femme et s'il ya
quelque chose comme une féminité
spécifiquement corse
je décide de revenir et je commence
cette quête avec ma grand mère mais en
famille c'est compliqué d'en parler
alors je rencontre d'autres femmes de sa
génération
d'autres mères et leurs filles d'autres
femmes sans enfant comme jeanine
comme thérèse
ou encore mini gaulle une centenaire
adorable et adoré par toute la
descendance surtout le jour de ses cent
ans la grand-mère de lucia
[Musique]
le grand père de me dire
la bonne anniversaire
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est un grand jour donc il
faut se mettre là à la
famille aux amis et à la
liberté
[Musique]
des
succès sans
soyez précieuse toujours ressortir mon
égard des bouches c'est l'omsl il de
nous envoyer chef
on a
entendu
[Applaudissements]
et alors
[Musique]
les gars
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde me demande où
est passé minigo
comme la chanson qu'il s'est
mêlé aux olympiades
et beaucoup de naissances au village tu
le sais que des filles mais là encore
les femmes du village les femmes ou gère
le village
[Rires]
comme ça on sera bien défendu
oui tout
après on est formaté par ceux qui nous
élève par nos parents mais nos grands
parents un rôle important je pense
surtout en tant que femmes nous on était
quand même assez proche parce qu'on
avait
ce lien par rapport à l'école par
rapport à piller pas beaucoup d'enfants
au village on n'était pas beau pas
n'importe qui en avait un à mon époque
quand j'étais à l'école on était sept
enfants tu imagines on était les rois du
village
donc là donc on était vraiment
chouchoutés un
pour la langue par exemple ses mimiques
d'avril
oui mais deux grands mères ouais moi
j'ai eu la chance dans mes deux grands
mères à au village
donc j'avais les deux qui me parlait en
cause
est bien aussi pour apprendre à écrire
l'avait de la patience parce qu'elle est
quand même les très intuitif savez bien
décrire lire que tu avais quand même
l'instruction c'était important aussi un
pour l'époque mais quand même jamais été
à l'école robert sabbah cbc pas bon à
l'époque pas tout le monde
donc tu as pu mitrailler club de cannes
nous atteler au pire tu m'as apprenait à
lire avec chloé way i am et
les femmes mais c'était quand même
les avs puisque l'avouer je pense à caen
demain mais elle était forte aussi un on
est toutes
tes giallo bonadio c'était quand même
catégorie à obernai tout le secondaire
tous les matins pour allumer le four
parce que maintenant c'est du folklore
quand on fait un lumière four à l'époque
c'était quand même découvrir pour leur
lobbying café contaminants ah oui
j'allais jouer
deux fois
c'était dur
finalement on est mis aujourd'hui un
final moi je choisis aujourd'hui moi je
n'ai pas encore à ça c'est vrai oui
ouais
on se plaint c'est dommage ou un toit
non parce que toi tu sais ce que tu as
vécu
et la difficulté de la vie de tous les
jours par rapport à aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui c'est que vous veniez vous
un point c'est tout
[Musique]
si la rumeur du matriarcat corse va bon
train avec les souvenirs de mini gaulle
je vois déjà les contours de ce mythe se
fissurer
[Musique]
tous aussi intensément ce qu'il est
possible de vivre et dessiner plus de 15
mais change
son histoire est celle d'un homme qui a
créé un héros je m'occupe de ma mère je
gère ma mère et tout en faisant plein de
choses à côté mais bon voilà ça fait 20
ans que je suis à la maison
et ailleurs
voilà il me vis dans mon fauteuil
voilà à tous ses services
non
moi je les fais avoir battu le faire
plus et ben voilà c'est mon rôle est de
toute façon
le mot roulin
pourquoi toi de par rapport aux autres
trésors parce que moi je suis pas marié
chéri moi j'ai décidé de ne pas me
marier
je voulais rester célibataire c'est un
confort c'est mon choix ouais c'est mon
choix
[Musique]
voilà célibataire pas d'enfant alléluia
voilà voilà mes frères viennent mais
surviennent quand elles peuvent aller
dans leur vie ils ont besoin d'autres
chats à fouetter et moi je jeu fouette
ma mère
si je me laisse le pouls et
voilà mais c'est bien
c'est très bien de pouvoir en profiter
un maximum
c'est ça
à
bonjour
parce que chez valve n'a pas d'où ça
oui moment on rappellera je peux pas
être au four et au moulin allez
en avant on rappellera à l'est
baste aller oui minceur
alors allez-vous ça c'est mon univers
oui c'est vrai il ya ya tout qui parle
ici mais celle qui me tient à coeur
c'est ça c'est quand j'étais bergère là
je suis au plateau d'al tu vois la voir
le cas boudabbous nahd et là c'était mon
fief tu vois je vais dire moi je souffre
de voir l'accord souffrir et d'où on
l'échappatoire c'est d'écrire donc j'ai
tout écrit mois de ce qui est devenu la
corde jusqu'à l'été de ce qu'elle est
devenue de voilà autant de chances donc
tout et tout et dans des textes et
traduit en langue française pour que
chacun puisse connaître la teneur du
texte soit mais c'est très fort il saad
hariri saad a dit me lie et dix plants
de riz et sa des riders a dit cet
entonnoir vous ignorent et la boule
soudas gouzy balle au niveai sadi a bien
nette à equal à thoune à 12 mai
my
les ou qe3
[Musique]
où
non
tout dire
[Musique]
ok
je suis très corse
j'ai
la terre de corse elle est attachée mais
mais je suis corse ces implantations
candidats
dont je vais à calais je suis pas plus
parce que cette hausse comme temps je
suis corse à marseille
à calvi par exemple je je
pour moi la corse c'est sa
voix
mais de grand mère paternelle et
maternelle ne savait ni lire ni écrire
et elles avaient toutes les deux 4 r non
ma grand mère maternelle trois frères
un qui était restée au village
mais qui ment elle en avait inquiété
notaires elle en avait un qui était
directeur de l'assistance publique à
marseille et en avait quand même l'été
conseil général marseille elle me savais
qu'elle était la fille et je pense que
ma mère ça
dans mon travail pour être ça et ma
grand mère paternelle
et des filles puissiez elle ne savait ni
lire ni écrire et ses trois frères
avaient des situations
on a déjà vu
ma maman tu sais à l'école tu vas
apprendre à lire tu vas apprendre à
écrire tu apprends beaucoup de choses
mais surtout travail bien des gueules
parce que plus tard tu pourra travailler
pour avoir un métier et tu seras
indépendante alors indépendante ou débat
et à jour je suis dit qu'est ce que ça
veut dire elle m'a répondu tu je ferai
ce que tu voudras tu pourras toujours
faire ce que tu veux mais elle me l'a
pas dit une fois seulement elle me le
disait tout le temps tout en comptant
et
je n'ai jamais fait que ce que je
voulais
un conseil sous des aspects
assez conciliant assez
je suis pas une révolutionnaire loin de
là mais je n'ai jamais fait que ce que
je voudrais
jamais
je
vais la culture m ça c'est mon frère
jusqu'à ce que mon frère tombe malade
je me sentais très jeune comme on ferait
tomber m avait 80 ans
il a été malade un an je vais soigner là
il a été à l'hôpital itou et puis ils
m'ont à la maison maintenant ça fait
trois ans que je suis seul je passerai
sont tous là
la maison était fait par mon père vient
tous les livres de mon frère il ya tous
ces arbres dit laplante et
il ya des choses qui va lui fait
dominique 10 sont bas
je fais ce que je suis avec toi
tu jamais seule on vous attend
allo
c'est marrant parce que ma mère est
morte quand j'avais 15 ans elle avait 44
ans et j'étais persuadé que
je devais mourir 44 ans
alors que maintenant je viens de me je
viens de faire un infarctus sans m'en
rendre compte dans dernier est bon je
suis arrivé quand même 1 83 ans mais ma
hantise moi c'était de laisser des
enfants en bas âge seul
il en était pas question à mon métier
c'est heureusement que j'ai eu mon
équipe quand j'étais instit à la
naissance je partais de la non et je
venais pas là puisque c'est le groupe
scolaire il est à l'ombre il s'est un
peu tous vos enfants ça finalement tout
serait ça c'est des déguisements fait
avec des sacs de farine
normal
et ça c'est dany boon a fêté le
bicentenaire de la révolution
trois ans probablement ma rigide en
grande forme ça ne manque pas d enfant
j'en ai 30 grande tous les jours devant
mes yeux donc ça me manque pas et mon
mari me a répondu mais moi ça me manque
pas je sais que s'il ne veut de nous que
voilà
[Musique]
l'indépendance dont vous parlez qui a
toujours été un leitmotiv pour moi de
manille
elle a quand même été freinée par le
sens par exemple dans le sens de la
famille il ne serait pas venu à l'idée
de laisser mon frère malade au v 240 où
il fallait que sur chez lui et j'ai fait
ce qu'il fallait quoi mais ça me
ya
si vous voulez j'étais mon libre je
n'étais plus montant n'était plus tout à
moi mais je le faisais pas ce que
j'avais envie de le faire donc
le frein que j'ai pu mettre à mon
indépendance
c'était d'été toujours dicté par
ont le sens de la famille ou le sens du
travail du le sens de
[Musique]
on
ne sait pas si c'est une qualité corse
l'italie t personnel ça j'en sais rien
[Musique]
le sens de la famille le respect de la
mer l'attachement à la terre
je me souviens en effet de ses valeurs
en écoutant judith je me suis souvenu
aussi que dans ma famille l'indépendance
des femmes n'était pas si évidente que
celle dont elle parle
[Musique]
alors l'indépendance de mater pour moi
ce n'était pas du tout une priorité
d'ailleurs ma grand-mère me disait que
c'était une affaire d'hommes et qu'on
n'avait rien à voir avec tout ça
avec les générations plus jeunes je
découvre comment les deux combats
d'indépendance des femmes et de la force
ont pu se réfléchir ensemble
comment une mère christiane a pu les
transmettre à sa fille anna laura moye
mon engagement il vient vraiment de loin
c'est à dire je voulais raconter c'est
assez particulier j'ai découvert un
nouvel essor de la corse j'étais en cm1
et je me suis j'ai eu une révélation je
me suis dit tiens on n'est pas je ne
suis pas française je suis corse on est
un peuple à part et donc j'ai fait du
prosélytisme à l'école d'ailleurs j'ai
retrouvé des amis dans que 40 ans 50 ans
cinquante ans après qui me rappelle de
moi et pas que je le faisais jouer à la
libération de la corse à l'école c'était
interdite par les corses ne parlait pas
corse et c'était vraiment ainsi
distinction sociale dire la mère de ce
prêt sciemment ne parle français et ont
considéré que c'était les les garçons a
limited comme ils avaient le droit de
sortir ou par les corses vont considérer
que les filles qui parlent les corses
étaient des filles des rues
non
en corse il ya plus de femmes et elles
sont intégrées dans les parties à
condition qu'elle se taise 1 vous le
sentez encore aujourd'hui will très
nettement plusieurs partis en tout cas
même dans les partis nationalistes je
vois que
les femmes sont vite mis sur la touche
ici à prennent trop de place et ça vole
dans votre engagement personnel vous
l'avez ressenti de fois c'était bien des
obstacles à votre moi je ne fais pas
j'ai jamais essayé de faire de la
politique électorale je dirais ça
m'intéresse pas spécialement j'ai fait
que 2010 anticipe c'est marrant et moi
du coup je retombe à chaque fois ce sont
mes pattes ou encore l'autre jouant des
femmes qui me disent ah mais non la
corse c'est un matriarcat c'est un homme
qui gère ces
animaux
dans les familles peut-être
par niveau politique mais par exemple
dans ton parti est-ce que donc une
question d'indépendance de la corse on a
pas que non dans le parti a vraiment
c'est mélanger c'est il ya des gens qui
sont pour l'indépendance à 100 % des
gens qui sont plus autonomistes c'est
pas
faire au groupe plusieurs idées dire
tant dans certains dansaient pas tout le
monde est sur le même si bon c'est vrai
saches tout c'est un point positif dans
cette voie l'indépendance des femmes n'a
à ce chapitre le sujet n'est même pas
bonne non non pas juste on
fait du tout
tu te sentirais toit de mener ça sur le
tapis
voudrais tu vas avoir l'opportunité de
faire et moment il ya toujours des
échéances politiques
finalement c'est compliqué d'avancer
parce que mes calendriers la balle en ce
moment le calendrier électoral effet que
je dois aussi se concentre que sur la
lune aura toujours quelque chose de
gratuit donc je pense que ça va être
compliqué votre cabinet du cellier là
depuis toujours
magnifique réunion politique à milan
cantonales y est depuis toujours et
c'est donc ça l eee pc mais je ne me
rappelle plus je me rappelle plus
elle raconte mais comment des deux
partout
[Musique]
je me suis vraiment épanoui dans la dans
la maternité j'aime j'aime et j'ai mis
mes enfants d'un amour absolu
du conglomérat
colle à nicolas ce vrai un amour mais
les deux absolue mais mais les douleurs
murphy devons arriver
c'est le fusionnelle versé vois je sais
pas souvent quand on était petit
mais j'ai grandi avec elle en fait et on
a regardé des films ensemble des
scieries des livres des jeux
on y croyait presque et moi je jouais à
droite plutôt normal parce que j'étais
enfant maintenant c'est plus du loing
pas forcément c'est plus dur je te
laisse plus faire
je ne sais pas ce soir il faut couper le
cordon non
c'est mon pack que le carton
ça arrive de dire ça c'est précisément
ce réseau
bon il faut
qu'on pourrait dire à base du coupé
couarde
dont l'un des parents tu l'a prise c'est
pas la peine que le corbeau
tout fait à peine est il exactement
c'est fou
c'est pas des enfants pour qu'ils
restaient collées à même de notre ville
allez
on est dans les bouteilles la
nfl il est glaçant
bonjour ça je remettais kt
oui j'ai horreur de voir des fêtes ah
bon
en étant n'a pas validé n'avait pas le
temps de faire des fêtes
oui j'avais 17 tu me racontait des fois
il y avait des fêtes mais
pas tout le monde pouvait y aller
moi la première
avec un enfant handicapé
et ses enfants un fan mais moi je te
plus de quoi pour
j'ai bien dit je fais une tête de
l'autre tomber ses pairs et est comme
jules et bien c'est pas vrai qu'est ce
que tu as un moment bien à l'eau des
gaules un peu
non
mais moi je vais rouler pour prendre le
goûter
allez je vais chercher la montée
de fiat
[Musique]
et
je
allez
si l'aide de ses côtés
allez c'est bon
il manque que toi ma chérie égalisa me
ann marie ève est arrivé avec une tarte
maison non on est bien parti là on est
dans le jardin
des cours aura demain ouais voilà ma
chérie ça va sa valise à quel dommage
que
tu regrettes ton temps nous bergère
ouais c'était mes plus belles années
pourtant c'est du rhin ouais 16 ans de
way des animaux jamais été déçoivent
jamais et puis quand tu fais ce métier
tu es 24 heures sur 24 sur le terrain tu
as même pas le droit de tomber malade il
faut être là tu vois moi l'année mise
bas ça c'était assez dur pour moi
oui elle avait pas d'autres bergère un
nom maintenant il y en a une a plus
maintenant
d'un métier d'homme c'est un métier
d'homme mouais
c'était bien il disait pour les autres
désormais ils étaient impressionnés de
toujours faire ça un peu ouais ouais les
vieux berger surtout il n'a plus le
dernier ce niveau là est le cas pour
aline
[Musique]
si l'on continue à parler d'indépendance
corse j'ai peur qu'on en vienne aux
fantasmes identitaire
là aussi j'ai du mal à y croire surtout
quand nos deux parents ne sont pas nés
au même endroit comme les miens ou comme
ceux de daniel à qui on a déjà demandé
de ne porter que son nom de famille
corse
quand j'écris mes publications ma mère
avait toujours cités parce que je trouve
c'est beau maouche 200 tonnes en plus la
musique et ça symbolise aussi ce le
courage de ma mère qui a épousé quand
même à l'époque
un homme qui était d'origine algérienne
bien qu'il ait eu la nationalité
française en corse c'est tout c'est
toujours dit qu elle sait à qui
appartient qu on doit toujours se situer
dans la lignée c'est à dire que en fait
l'individu n'existe pas à plus forte
raison la notion d'individu femmes ça
alors et moi j'ai pas rougir de mon père
je n'ai pas à prouver quoi que ce soit
voilà je suis danièle maoudj et puis
voilà pourquoi je vais prouver il y en a
du fric à blizzard il ya didier et son
goût boursin une sodomie quand date
amende par aline goa gucht je n'ai aucun
problème avec
avec ce que je suis voilà et en général
ce sont des gens
qui sont pas sûrs d'eux qu'ils sont qui
sont fragiles qui ont besoin de prouver
moi j'ai pas besoin de mettre une croix
autour du cou j'ai pas besoin de m uribe
d'où un moment donné quand c'était la
mode ou sont concédés au fait qu'est ce
que ça veut dire on est là bas c'est le
hasard de la vie sur les pénètre à
stockholm un wet tombouctou donc
[Musique]
cette hystérisation trous autour de
l'identité en fait ça masque la lutte
des classes pendant ce temps parle pas
des vrais problèmes sociaux des
injustices sociales
des gens qui souffrent des gens
précaires au nom de l'identité c'est
comme si on était tous en famille qui
avait pas de dominer de dominants en
corse personne n'exploite personne tout
le monde à la même enseigne non c'est à
l'heure là aussi c'est un leurre
[Musique]
moi le régionalisme oui moi je pense
qu'on est je pense qu'on est un
territoire à part c'est vrai on est une
île déjà par définition attention je
vais pas faire de politique maintenant
avec poniatowski qui a quitté le
contraire de ce qu'il fallait faire il a
cru qu'on mater les corses avec de
l'aide avec de la force c'est ne rien
comprendre aux corses
les corps sont les maths pas avec la
force one quelqu'un m'a dit j'ai cette
espèce comme jeanine de vieux airs de
vieux de vieilles résistance ancestrales
peut-être qu'il dut à l'autre et à nos
prêts à notre histoire qui fait qu on
est tout le temps on a été vendus envahi
données français anglais go wisigoths
tout ce qu'on veut donc ça a créé chez
nous une une mentalité de résistance un
réflexe aulas on la sème en qualité de
rêve et de résistance et quand on est si
on veut nous faire faire quelque chose
il faut surtout pas passer par hbo il
faut faire alors certainement pas bon
alors ça je vais te dire dans à faire
une famille aussi c'est pareil cas sur
tout à fait
6 ans et ça fait partie de notre de
notre de notre très forte entre
addiction
alors vous qu'est ce que vous en pensez
tout ça
moi je m'interroge du coup c'est pour ça
que je rencontre différentes femmes pour
m'interroger là dessus
[Musique]
est ce qu'on voulait conclure un peu
jeanine surtout ils animeront conclu moi
je veux avoir des scuds je conclus
totalité dit qu'est ce qu'on nourrit que
je disais à 88 ans
il me semble est ce que je me trompe
[Musique]
où
chivu mai dernier jeanine trois
ans basso fatigue et des vernis
maintenant formidable n'a rien sans rien
mais en france paye
ça c'est sûr
et vous aurez une des filles j'ai eu
deux filles mais beauté fatale
avec leur mère
maternelle est magnifique
on me soigne et me dorlote on me
remet gâteau me pourrit
on me chouchoute
on me voit
d'abord vieille grosse panne élevé
sur ce sur ces belles paroles
l'envi se précise
tiens prends moi ça
suburbains alif
le seabourn lourdes lourdes lourdes
petite vieille bourde
[Musique]
dans les temps se mettaient beaucoup de
noix aux yeux
sur les cils et job
mais ça m'allait bien très bien même ça
me lire si c'est beaucoup
allez je fasse attention de pas trop m
je me suis arrêté j'en ai assez dit rien
voilà il faut se coiffe la
non savarin sport est comme ça
m'en fiche
cette affaire
c'est même trop bien
notre école
moi j'ai fais tu sais ça tombe bien
chérie j'ai très faim ça tombe bien si
tu as ça regarde
gad
[Musique]
oui je dis impliqué un moment donné
ma faim
sur le vieux port il paraît
moi quand j'étais petit je descendais de
classe du pensionnat
j'ai déposé mon cartable dans la
boutique d'antiquités de maman la
brocante
et j'allais fermer de voir un côté au
café d'à côté il y avait une clientèle
un peu très masculine
les beaux gosses de bastia un peu
frimeur un peu mais charmant jusqu'au
jour où
tu peux raconter maman je vous ai et les
bacs dès des
mâles dans la porte
des coups de feu dans la vitrine oui
je dis là il ya quelque chose qui ne va
pas
quand un jour bien me garder
moi
ça fait la meilleure
mesure renseigné j'ai compris que vous
êtes et des mafieux
et c'est elle et ça me brise de mer
c'est une fête comme peu au courant oui
oui qui était au courant mais tu te
rendais pas compte de l'ampleur que ça
avait pris en corse de la lampe l'heure
de cette
mafia
très active quand même
si tu veux pas que je te la coupe un peu
un morceau plus tendres et ça te ferait
du bien maman un
nom j'ai un peu de viande ça te donne
des forces enfouies
mère
maman c'était
fini eh ben
vous croirez ou pas ça ne me fait n'est
point des flots
[Musique]
si je vous dis que ma grand mère corse
et s'est jamais baigné une seule fois
j'y crois c'est quand même curieux à se
demander si les femmes avaient envie de
prendre du bon temps je me demande
je me pose la question dans quel sens le
truc bien d'aller sur une plage c'est
aller au soleil de ce billet se
retourner comme une crêpe
or non
c'est leur disait rien faut croire que
ce n'était pas elle essaie doriz et pas
un sou souvent certaines femmes ne
s'autorisait pas à ce doux oui mais
enfin c'est ridicule ça oui mais c'est
l'époque qui voulait ça aussi c'est
récent lehman maire sait pas si ce
serait formulée il ya eu toujours une
île les privilégiés qui faisait ça mais
les c'est vrai qu'elle est de ne pas
enlever un front populaire à c'était
nouveau un regardent ils n'allaient pas
la plage et partez pas en vacances les
gens sains
oui c'est vrai un peu
enfin bref voulu des maillots
[Musique]
pas
ouah
hu
moi
[Musique]
jours
d
l'eau
[Musique]
et
beau
[Applaudissements]
l'eau
au
[Musique]
pas
et
[Applaudissements]
les leaders
mua
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
toi tu peux donner l'énergie et d'argon
pour que si c'est pas bon que ça semble
ardue comprend voilà la titre au
contraire j'étais contrainte très bien
alors au nom du père du fils et du
saint-esprit avait
gesù
est ce prêt à faire valoir
tous
[Musique]
après la télé la protection genre de
course ottawa et vous voilà en amont
regardes et tu sais que tout ça se sent
et que ce sont des rites païens
est bon alors je pense que si évoqué le
mont dieu évoqué de diass
est ce que tu penses pas par exemple que
ça vient pas parce que là c'est un peu
un hasard mais on se sent de rituels qui
se transmet comme s'amortir qui se
transmettent pendant qu'elle à metz oui
et ça me savons pas dire que si tu vois
là mais ce que tu dois voyant voilà et
oui non mais je me demandais ce que
c'est pas la réflexion
wamala bg group en belgique rien bon ben
c'est sûr je voudrais m'adresser à avoir
la télé oui c'est très complexe tout ça
ça c'est ce sont des choses qui s'est
depuis la nuit des temps chez au moins
depuis que
fin mois de ça fait
50 ans donc je pratique ça alors tu sais
les gens viennent
au
[Musique]
moins dix habitants
il
pendant
[Musique]
j'avais oublié à quel point en corse nos
féminité ont pu parfois se construire
dans notre rapport à la religion
chez toutes les femmes que j'ai
rencontrées il ya eu une transmission du
sacré par la mer par les grands maîtres
chez chacune un vécu singulier de ce
sacré a ensuite fait d'elle les femmes
qu'elles sont aujourd'hui
rosana m'a initié à ses pouvoirs tandis
que christiane me raconte ses croyances
la vierge aux étagères avec voilier de
vie vous savez que c'est assez commun
avec beaucoup de mamans qui ont perdu un
enfant dis moi pourquoi j'ai ce rejet de
la vierge parce que il ya notre dame de
la vase in kou connaissait
j'avais été l'ami mon fils est mort
j'avais été priés notre de la voisine en
faisant trois voeux et en particulier
que mon fils vive et tant qu'il est mort
et on l'enterrait le jour de la base in
au départ je voulais rencontrer
christiane pour son courage de femmes
qui apportait des hommes intouchable et
puissants devant un tribunal
s'il est vrai que la figure maternelle
est respectée chez nous autant en
profiter alors pour prendre la parole
la femme en tant que maire respecter
encore ça c'est vrai si la femme en tant
que femme qui a un rôle qui doit on dise
ici des gens rester à sa place prendre
la mer tant que maire ici encore ce
talent est reconnu et donc dans le
combat que je venais avec pour le faire
condamner les hommes vie c'était la mer
donc ça a été
le silence je ne pouvais pas donc
c'était où je me venge est tout seul et
ça je suis incapable non seulement
moralement ni physiquement ni moralement
c'était pas possible donc j'ai choisi la
voie de la justice de faire appel la
justice française ce qui m'a marc
baucher d'ailleurs cela car où je
voulais dit au procès m'a dit vous
disent nationalistes vous faites appel à
la justice française moi je lui dis la
justice je me suis tourné vers lui je
lui dis la justice corps c'est là
qu'elle s'est lui sans ce n'est pas
celle que j'ai choisie
moi je pense que le nationalisme a
réouvert les églises même si les corses
pratiqué mais pratiquée de façon païenne
moi je dirais moi ma mère elle n'a
jamais jamais parlé toutes les femmes de
la famille jamais il ya eu ce rapport de
folie à l'église catholique mais jamais
jamais j'ai d'ailleurs n'avait pas la
messe mais ce qu'on fait c'est pas
analysé toujours j'ai pas vu me
confesser à globe
donc et pourtant elle avait elle croyait
en dieu avant de mourir la pauvre elle
elle priait mais on vit beaucoup sur les
mythes encore son rôle et l'histoire et
ça c'est quand même dangereux 1 le culte
de la vierge marie
damas la madone lamerat qui est la
madone moi je pense qu'en corse il n'y a
que des maires et des fils c'est des
rapports fusionnels avec ben y'a qu'à
voir un n'aurait pas besoin d'affirmer
comme ça leur virilité ses six frères
hommes
avec leurs flingues
c'est peut-être caricatural mais c'est
aussi une réalité 1
oh
non
que
peut-être et
oui
ça
[Musique]
là
oh
[Musique]
on
moi je suis ici j'ai ce soc sous ce
marronnier tant chéri de mon père et de
ma mère et de ma famille 100 tonnes mais
je suis ouverte au monde c'est ça qui
est important
je suis désespérément optimiste
parce que je suis était pessimiste je
serai prétentieuse et si j'étais
optimiste je serais vraiment bête donc
il faut allier les contraires et trouver
la voie médiane pour justement
travailler faire éclore votre pensée
le seigneur est avec
mais
je me rends à une dernière procession
apens kerrache
je suis heureuse de voir que ce sont des
femmes cette fois qui porte la mer
madone peut-être que je trouve ça plus
logique moins hypocrite
en tout cas je ne crois toujours pas à
cette fiction du matriarcat corse et
encore moins après avoir rencontré les
femmes de ce documentaire
à la limite l'accord serait à mes yeux
un patriarcat comme un autre mais
particulièrement géré par les femmes des
femmes qui se sont fait une place qui se
sont fait entendre
la réducation par l'héritage d'une mère
par choix professionnel
par militantisme par classe sociale ou
par hasard elles se sont toutes forgé
leur indépendance
[Musique]
mais une île c'est un miroir grossissant
alors je crois qu'ici plus qu'ailleurs
nous devons démentir les rumeurs et
refonder certains de nos mythes ce que
vous avez un avis là dessus
sur le rôle de la femme ce le rôle de la
femme parce qu'il m'aime pour le poser
un peu avec humour aux commandes encore
poids mais je pense vraiment que c'est
les femmes et les hommes oui
malgré les apparences réseau pas
s'étonner si long que en première ligne
vous avez toujours la figure masculine
c'est normal c'était sont des matches où
les corses y sont attendus carrière ils
sont
comment dirais-je exubérant ils sont
excessifs y sont mais en deuxième ligne
c'est toujours la femme la mère en
particulier cela mr avait requis au
maire de pavie oui oui c'est sûr
moi j'ai pas dans ce débat je sais pas
vous tuer bolan moi c'est pareil et en
fait on est on est en équipe angie aussi
les parties
et bien mesdames j'espère que nous
rejoindrons assez vite la première ligne
dont vous parlez
mais déjà je suis rassuré de ne pas
avoir à choisir entre la maman et la
la sainte vierge ou l'hérétique
il est mon jeu
d1
[Musique]
oui
ce pas
[Musique]
nous avons déjà aidé c'est cool et des
maladies
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]